so how would an AI
detect what arranged the zeros and ones
dude it's like it's like with
synthesizers and and dance music that I
make like if you know how this syn is
supposed to sound on the in the actual
vintage version and you can already make
those parameters effect the same way
that it would you can fool even somebody
who knows this this original sense as
long as you understand oh it's going to
variate over this amount of time I'm
going to put this parameter on here and
variate that that particular parameter
over this amount of time and it's in
almost IND discernable and the the
computer that's that available now is so
much more powerful than something made
in 83 or 7 whatever you know it's and
and and what and and again to the
computer at the very basic level it's
just zeros and ones how do you tell what
arranged the zeros and ones how do you
tell that it was a human that took a
picture that's how those zeros and ones
got arranged on the you know whatever
format you're putting it on or they were
arranged by an AI because at the end of
the day that file is just zeros and ones